yeah there's a pattern
okay let's uh
keep on the opening tour here
there goes e5 i thought he would go c6
and he's got of course he's going to go
for the
reversed offer uh reversed um
close to sailing here
hmm
so interesting usually black goes for f5
before knight f6
so i can try one of two plans here one
which is to go b3
bishop b2 and so on d3 and trying to be
flexible that way
or i can go for a quick rook b1 b4
for me it's hard to tell which one is
best let's go d3
95 i think 98 is the move you're
supposed to play here maybe this way
knight c3 98 b4
so on okay let's exchange first then
i feel like this is something that they
write about
in a in an old
doritsky book
i'm pretty pretty sure i've seen
like this exact
exact structure
i can't say that i have much though
let's try and advance
but realistically i don't have
don't have too much to hope for this in
these positions i've played this
i've over thought it and i played it too
soft
but a lot can still
still happen
yes deciding whether to go knight d6
the i36 are to go 97.
should i go d4 now
seems sort of wrong
i don't particularly like my position
okay let's go d4
try and change the the character of the
position a little bit
maybe f4 is good u4
ed knight d4
probably not clear
it takes 96 i'll go 92.
because bishop e3 that was f4 now he has
got d5
but i'm loving the fact that once the
position opens up
he has weak weakened his king with f5 so
that's what i'm sort of
backing on so he's trying to open up
this way
can i go b6
should i go b6 yeah i think i should
trying to soften up his structure a bit
c6 i go with d5
in general i'm trying to open up the
position because his king is a little
bit weaker
so spawn would love to be back on well
even f8 but
preferably f7
like do you find now
didn't see that coming
does bishop a3 make any sense
if i go to c5 you can close up with c6
so i don't like that
um
okay let's go bishop a3 then
clock is obviously a little bit of a
worry at some point as well
i think rook f7
i'm allowing f4
it really really really wasn't called
for
f4 cd maybe
maybe f4 f3
now at least i can take
i don't have any time let's go back i
can give up d4
i'm fine with that i just don't want to
get any
f4 shenanigans
g5 maybe for myself
looks dicey let's go knight f4
try and try and exchange simplify the
game a bit
since i am there's pretty short
time this may be a weakness but
also maybe a strength
i don't think he's going to take but why
not pre-move
he's catching up with me on time so
that's good
yeah it's logical but now i'm fine
now i'm probably probably even better
see one rook c7
let's take it 96 knight c5 to come
starting to look very promising
okay knight c5
i wrote d5 i didn't see but
maybe there was nothing to see rook c1
probably winning now grab it
should be technically winning
we push
this is the one that i didn't see
okay
messing this up a bit it's
very resourceful in defense
okay i should still win let's just go
grab
grab everything that i can still
push
yeah just push work ending is easily
winning
i think you can just give up b6 at this
point because the h pawn is queening
this one will take
good stuff only one draw in a row this
time before i started winning again